machine as you're in the past what's
happening there reject nation we're back
at it eight weeks later you know
superman lois likes to do it for
bizarros in a bizarro world superman and
lowest people hey if you can leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated
would be very appreciated if you become
a super sexy reject today by checking us
out on patreon we will get the full
length watch along for this show over
there as long as
along with much better shows
subscribe and click that notification
bell you what our next reaction for snl
is up
and uh boys at prepper you're the real
kent brothers in my mind and there's
more than just youtube all right
let's go
i've had so long to reflect on the last
episode
nice
how much reverse [ __ ] can we do
the whole episode's backwards it's
memento superman
whoa
so he was like in the between space for
a minute
[Music]
hurry still grabs
[Music]
flat earth or square
square earth
nice use of meta backwards-ness did he
send you
my son healed guys get on
not exactly
how did he do that
if he concentrates really hard
and the alley of my world is here as
well and it is only a matter of time
before she becomes the most powerful
being on this planet it is simply not
possible for humans to coexist with
beings of that magnitude
which is happening we'll take this with
us all right allie allison knows you're
here how's that possible i'll explain
later we need to get to the farm it's
the safest place to hide out it looks so
tiny
the scope of this green screen effect is
a little
funky
how do we find her
my guess says she sold the dod the dod
what's dod backwards in this world
it's the best named organization
palindromes are the key
you have more strength than my dad i
guess
i i assume you met him when he escaped
the earth to be a hero again
i did yes who's dead isn't he
knew we'd fail
huh jeez the two of you didn't get along
yeah let's let's just say that we didn't
exactly see eye to eye on some decisions
i made
the eyeliner i had the earrings did he
even mention i existed he didn't really
have a chance yeah because he didn't
care yes he did jonathan whoa he loved
you enough
you should have disappeared like i told
you to yeah lydia dietz
it's a interesting
structure can we please just try to have
one nice night together as a family you
know it doesn't happen often with your
dad's schedule
yeah whatever
i have to get out there
just try to enjoy yourselves what a
weird ass episode
the
boys uh how about we just get a picture
for these guys thank you so much we're
like your biggest fans oh well i know a
lot of people like you what cameo is
this
looks like jonathan finally got his
powers he can finally see what i deal
with on a daily basis
[Music]
there is like a boy's quality to this
yeah
super blood joins the seven
[Music]
i have so many feelings
he does not do that comfortably no so
it's a full body exercise
he's trying to flex under there
how did those trucks get in that
position
they were at a truck stunt rally
it's always
always about me understanding you maybe
for once in your life you should think
about how i'm feeling it's like the
osbournes
[Laughter]
i was supposed to meet misty 20 minutes
ago but i'm here now jonathan oh it's
not always about you pups
so he's like always in his suit yeah i
guess that's just warner brothers tower
huh was it was it cubed out too yeah
it just seems like ever since we've met
you've been trying to find yourself
which is why there's someone i'd like
you to meet
so they're super wealthy but still live
on that farmhouse
yeah i've got an image to uphold i guess
jonathan l
but he disregarded the kent name
whatever
fix jonathan a cup of tea don't tell him
anything he's working for ally
jonathan
now
you're gonna tell me where i can find
those pendants
this is such a
this episode is definitely bizarre yeah
i am just as responsible for what
happened as you are but jonathan never
felt heard or seen and it turned him
into somebody i can hardly recognize
damn bizarre you not have your [ __ ]
under control this life this family
all of it was me
i will find him
ah dude you move
you die
project four three seven seven anal
it's lana
[Laughter]
right you are
where's four three seven seven we never
taught you what was really important in
life it's not magazine covers or talk
shows or some signature move last chance
gramps tell me right now sorry i wasn't
a better mother
i know that i failed you
jordan's just there to stand and look
mopey
everyone stop fighting
follow me
you son of a [ __ ]
but you're not going to join us then
disappear
there won't be
any countries this would be the end of
humanity as we know it so how do we get
to ali before that happens we can't
but i can't oh god take the pendant and
i'll make it to the other earth hmm
you're going to tell me where i can find
those pendants
are they where are the planets
stop it i don't know where are they
you're going to tell me where anderson
is you're going to end up just like my
dad
[Music]
and backwards
this is clearly like a we could only do
this for one episode
where is
she i want those pendants
kryptonian
juice jonathan before they merge
oh no
now
[Laughter]
no it shouldn't
i
i don't think that's supposed to be fun
there's a moment for backwards
[Music]
i like how it's also bully mcguire world
no one's seen her since the dod was
taken over please
you need to leave
how did he understand that
[Laughter]
thank god christie was quick on her feet
luckily i got to him before ali's forces
did
christy's all right in this world sir do
you know what happened to my dad
he went to your world
what does that mean george what does
that mean
afraid your father's dead
i speak backwards jordan
okay
did you hear that
that loud stopping above you guys
that caused that dust to fall out of the
ceiling
you mean the thing that just happened
outside obviously
anderson
you were right
i can't let ally get dependents
all you have to do is throw him into a
fridge
that's the biggest weakness
[Laughter]
hard enough thrown to the fridge
back in the fridge john
i'm sorry
i'm so sorry
let's get you and those pendants out of
here
they're coming
hey
don't let her get these put this up your
ass
i said
now
oh
get back to our earth
oh no
one specifically for jonathan
[Music]
negron
oh
cool
this is chaos magic wander
oh
not well planned anderson
rob zombies lords of smallville
[Music]
now at last we could come home
why did clark just keep that in his hand
like a pocket or something bud
yes
i don't want to play square pool lois is
pregnant are you serious i'm gonna be an
uncle you're gonna be an uncle
i'm gonna be an uncle
the rest of the night the drinks are on
me
that's not how you afford to pay for a
kid
because responsibility is now unknown i
got a lot of thirsty customers taking
you up on your offer i'm gonna need a
credit card
i promise you i'm good for it it's not
like i don't know who you are
world's most eligible bachelor
don't believe everything you read in
persons magazine i'm um persons
uh what was i thinking
maybe this is a mistake tell you're just
nervous
you and lana are the happiest couple i
know
they're always in their outfits
[Laughter]
do like the choice that all the
lifestyles are different yeah
you just destroyed my family
please
just give me your word give me your word
you will walk
away it's complicated lana really
believes in what she's doing [ __ ]
woman then that's always the one goddamn
jade amber [ __ ] man i'm saying yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
the birth of blue eyes
what is she becoming
tell me if we didn't think this through
although
oh wow
[Laughter]
i failed my brother once before
seeing you here reminds me what i lost
tall
wind breath
how neat that's cool effect
oh
supes
hey look
john's home oh
why are you here
oh boy tram
let's get this on and let's get started
oh what the [ __ ] i know
gonna have a big old fight at the
beginning of the next one are we like
the end of the season or something
huh are we at the end of the season or
something
no is it like the second to last episode
no
can't be right
no
no it's not no
that'd be stupid
no not this episode but i feel like are
we getting close to the end there's only
like 10 to 16 episodes i think somewhere
that seems about right okay all right
all right i'll calm down that was wacky
that was wild yes it was a wacky ass
episode people it was
the whole time
practically i kept thinking to myself
this is one of those episodes
that's either going to be you know like
like a charming left turn
or something that really doesn't work
and i feel like it didn't really end up
being a hundred percent of either but i
i really enjoyed what this episode was
doing
i feel like how it did a lot of it so i
it kept dipping in and out of for me of
like sometimes it was really working and
then sometimes it was kind of silly and
then it would it would very erratically
kind of move between those two flavors
but i think i liked it though
ah
i'm i'm really like in the middle on it
i'm not i'm not the biggest fan of this
episode it's definitely not the most
consistent of the season already like
this feels like
you know it makes sense because it's
bizarro world to a degree but it feels
like a different show a little bit
just the sensibility is different
[Music]
yeah
uh i felt like i watched a lot of
information yes
and
i often credit this show on being
something that's very emotional
and i'm like i don't really
i don't have
i don't really care
about most of
like i care to like know what's
happening and i was interested
in what was happening and it is weird
and disjointed it feels like they tried
to
utilize that purposefully
but a lot of it doesn't
work
for me a lot of it's very s
this is it it's
it's strange and not in
the
the way a good way i think it ought to
be strange
it's
i didn't
the pacing is off
oh absolutely it's a weird paced one so
it took me a minute to pick up on
what was happening too because like a
few minutes in to the john flashback i
realized that was a flashback
but like the whole yeah delivery system
of like cutting back and forth to the
present and then doing these anthology
what happened just before now stories
yes
it was
none of them felt like they were
proportioned to each other
no i think it was moving i think it
moved way too quick and they jammed way
too much in 40 minutes yeah oh yeah
this felt like
i mean it's it's different if like this
was a comic in a weird way this felt
like one of the more comic book-y
episodes i think we've seen
like if this was a graphic novel or like
an issue as part of a series
i would
i would not say that
um i'd probably be really into it and it
really and really absorb it oh yeah
there's a lot of contextual pieces i
really like
uh i like how it's not just
the appearances and some people are
swapped it's the like the lifestyles are
are complete opposite
in
in almost every way i think the thing
that was probably the most confusing to
me
was the reverse language and when it
wasn't reverse language and how some
people understood each other by way i'm
having a hard time wrapping my brain
around
why can they sometimes understand them
and apparently they're not and it's it's
a different language but it's
but it's not a different language i
thought on this planet they just talked
in reverse i'm kind of that's where i
was
uh
a little lost but besides that one
little point i think they
it this was like a medley of a lot of
things that i think should probably
be
it's really gloomy and ominous and not
really ominous it's really it's really
gloomy and dreary and and a constant
sense of uh
like a
weird like a apocalyptic on the on the
verge kind of vibe yet
i i didn't
um
i didn't feel
much of anything yeah i wasn't ever like
charmingly
strange in a fun way
it it had i don't even know exactly what
it this kind of felt like a 90s 2000s
comic book movie to me like one of the
bad ones
yeah absolutely
because it is i mean it's so much of
like
it really feels like they had this
really cool fun idea and only had one
episode to do it so they took their shot
but ultimately that makes it so that
it's yeah mostly just a bunch a bunch a
bunch a bunch of info and then i it's
like i would find myself intermittently
appreciating choices where i'm like okay
in this version of the world everybody
is quicker to confrontation and anger or
something like that so that's why you
have so much shouting and screaming um
but it didn't seem to be much underneath
the surface but there didn't
and it started to feel like a soap opera
like there were times where i would get
into this performances and i would be
like okay this is kind of good scene
back and forth but there were other
times where i would be like they're
playing dress-up they're playing
you know it's hard to assemble big
effects for tv shows especially but this
also had the least convincing effects i
think of any of the superman hello
episodes we've watched and it's again
like i really liked what they were
trying to do but i feel like so many of
the elements
that usually coalesce to make it feel
like both the comic but also a really
engrossing drama in this make it feel
like yeah some kind of 90s 2000s comic
book movie meets some kind of soap opera
that takes place adjacent to the snyder
verse or something because i was
thinking too well like when they were
doing some of the other kal-el stuff i
was like it would be kind of intense and
scary to be safe by this guy it feels
like because he's just so on edge
yeah i mean it was it was doing that
when i say like 92 000 when that's like
let's try to be a little edgy let's go
for that like that emo gothic vibe but
they didn't even really commit to that
like i felt like the
that no pun intended here i feel like
the lane they decided to go down they
weren't committing
fully to whichever direction they wanted
like there's a lot of like i said a lot
of context pieces i really admire
um
uh the idea that kal-el here
uh is not
doesn't give a [ __ ] about a secret
identity and he embraces the l name he
doesn't go by clark kent he goes by cal
l this family is elves and the house
they live in
um you know he's friends with his
he's he's close with his brother
and i like that actually i think
out of things that i thought were
genuinely good
i liked the scene of them at the bar uh
one scene not in their costumes and and
the scene at the the what i thought the
wedding scene was good like their i
thought their scenes
felt the most natural even when
he's breaking down and um oh my god keep
like consistently blank on how to say
his name
taro i guess
yeah that's right r o o
is there an l in there that's my
question
is there a ton see i was trying to
figure it out here because i've seen a
spell with an h and an l and in this
episode it sounded like they were saying
towel like towel row with an l okay so
for today that's what it'll be
all right so
the tauro
um
that that yeah their scenes felt the
most sincere and
genuine whereas everything else was kind
of like a whole bunch of
you see like with the other characters
take john henry irons for example when
you cut to his earth you spread that out
over the course of multiple episodes
you you build the mystery of these of
like the the specific story they want to
tell of your key memory in his life
and you
and then and you cut back to it and you
want you unpack it over time
and then here it was
uh it was just jam packing a whole bunch
of
things that i don't think fits with this
season
other than getting the necessary
information i don't think
this uh flows with the rest of the
season
uh at all and i
and and it
things just came across like
unintentionally goofy
when they seemed like they were going
one for edge yeah and wait
like jonathan's
bad boy jonathan just came across like
whiny
teenager and then jordan
yeah and then jordan was just [ __ ]
like nothing new he was just there to be
like guys stop
stop fighting me but not even that much
dialogue
yeah i i i felt like lois was playing
dress up i felt like lana was definitely
playing dress up like especially the
actress plays lana
you know i didn't get a sense of history
of anyone's performances
and
um which is a bummer because you want to
when you're in bizarre world like i feel
like that could have been one of those
things where
if they'd either spread these flashes
either throughout the season or maybe
once we've established bizarro and had
that sort of first act of the season
then you could mix these glimpses in on
the other side
because you have so many things that
harmonize with and complement like
jonathan's uh turn with xk and and the
way that he even offers clark upon a
rival you know kryptonite
and you know there are so many things in
the season about parallels and i feel
like there's so much to play with there
like you can i mean like you were saying
the lifestyles are all different and i
was thinking it's kind of interesting to
watch kyle in this world be this very
like stern father who is very much about
his family legacy and he's very like you
know about business until it you know
unlike clark he's emotionally closed off
yeah exactly exactly and like that was
was interesting and engrossing and like
i feel like this episode is frustrating
because throughout there were these
little glimpses like when they really
got into an interesting character beat
or something like that there were
interesting glimpses into how cool this
could have been to explore throughout
because it doesn't seem also like it
would be that expensive to do more
bizarro world stuff
seems like it's mostly about costuming
and tinting everything red and you know
having certain backward flourishes so i
i feel like they could have made a lot
out of that for this season that would
be
there to serve as you know further uh uh
sort of
in
inspections of these characters rather
than here's kind of a cool what amounts
to like a neat side quest where we get
to see a bunch of bizarro versions of
people and and we spend like a a
feverish interlude there but then we're
pretty much gonna be back on regular
this felt like the most cw episode i've
ever seen of the show absolutely totally
um and i think that's uh
one of the main compliments of this show
is it doesn't feel like a cwu show but
this this really did feel like
because normally with the cw shows when
i was really watching them um
uh
my my term of latest religiously when i
was really watching them religiously
it
it was very uh it's like ben was
watching that's how i would do it i
would binge watch them
and if this was part of my binge i would
just move on like i wouldn't i wouldn't
stop the show and just be like all right
next episode
i wanted
someone to ruminate and go here's
everything i didn't like about this
episode
but we're talking about weeks a week if
we're going to sit back and talk about
it yeah i got i got a lot of issues with
the way this was handled i don't i don't
at the end of the day if it's not really
emitting an emotion
um then it it falls weak to me despite
how cool
ideas are you know and it
is that you were doing like
let's try to see as many people in
opposite world as you can and let's even
get anderson story wrapped up here yeah
you know let's try to do let's try to do
it all when i was like i think the core
of this would have been the tragic
the tragedy of
cal-l in this world i think if they just
focused on that
if you did like a two-parter episode in
some way yeah and really make the weight
of his sacrifice ring yeah because this
was
this was just all over the place and
then this like [ __ ] tarantino
approach would like cutting cutting
between different chapters is always
like a cool film school gimmick
but uh if not done right you're just
kind of
watching [ __ ] happen
you know yeah that's what's so
frustrating about this is is that it
for me it's like i really enjoyed the
experience of watching this episode but
a good chunk of that enjoyment is ironic
or or is in spite it's like my uh not in
like angry spite but you know it's like
this is an episode that for me i'm like
oh this is aimed at me like i i i wanted
something great and yeah this as it
stands is kind of wacky
developed they felt prey to
so many short scenes but a lot of them
and so heavy on exposition and it pretty
much did all the things i
i've credited superman and lois for not
doing it
yeah yeah it makes the experience for as
dense as it is and for as fast as you're
moving and for as little as you're
connecting with everybody it does make
it feel like this sort of weird fever
dream interlude like i'm curious to see
if it'll come back in any way or how the
next episode will feel because it feels
like we just like rushed through a
highlights reel of stuff
and we like you know anderson is uh
ostensibly just dead now so
you know in a way
like my favorite moments of his were in
this episode and i'm like okay he's dead
now and i feel like that impact is
probably going to be blunted by just the
episode around it and all the chaos i
don't i you had
all the super super people there all the
people with the kryptonian powers right
and i other than a couple of moments
i really did not care for i don't mean
to just [ __ ] on this episode all i can
do is be honest yeah and i did find
myself going this is kind of this is
weak action because it's just
the flying could be looking cool some of
the collisions but it's like this same
old it was just like so generic of just
like get them close right hook right
hook right hook yeah right hook left
hook right hook left hook i'm like
there's nothing it's so repetitive and
yeah like you got all the people here
and you're not this broad power set yeah
this should be you know and and you got
this isil i was like okay you're i
should be a nightmare you're isolating
them together you know you're isolating
them here on the farm on the on the
ranch yeah and i i thought this is when
you could probably do one of your like a
really cool fight that can make this all
worth it and
um they didn't too it was uh
it it really is just like get close hot
right hook that was the fighting if it
felt like they didn't really have much
time like i don't
knowing how the show is i give the
benefit of the doubt of like it feels
like they had no time to make this or
something because just everything like
even just the green screening of the
action and the some of the flight does
just look awkward and usually they do an
exceptional job i think of making that
stuff look cool and impactful and i
think the physics too in this episode
sort of suffer and part of you i think
can go well it's bizarro world physics
are different but at the same time it
started to feel too ragdoll and too much
like you know when he throws them into
that car and the car just like shoots
over there and and something feels sort
of artificial it just adds to that
feeling of it being artificial rather
than it feeling like you've stepped into
sort of a heightened comic world
this is not a i really don't think this
is a nitpick then we got to wrap this up
uh i really don't think this is a
nitpick
when anderson throws him into the fridge
yeah the fact that it knocked him out
completely that's that's honestly when i
feel like this episode lost me
because i was already like kind of
losing it a little bit you know um
despite liking some concepts especially
this whole thing with like monetize
kal-el
i
when he gets knocked into the fridge i'm
like
if you're gonna knock this guy out
he wouldn't land in a fridge
you would be like in the fridge flying
through the walls
yeah it would have to be like through
the fields it has to be like such a hard
throw no dude to knock it same one
indiana jones survived the nuclear
it's it's not it just that suddenly
like what that there's no way that would
have knocked him out unless i've
completely missed something yeah there
there's no way that would have knocked
him out yeah that's a good point unless
it was like some kind of super crazy ass
lead fridge
yeah last question did it ever feel to
you like they did some of the bizarro
performances and or dialogue like
literally with the actors speaking
backwards only to then play it forwards
because i feel like there's there were
times where it really sounded like
certain people's dialogue had been
recorded that way but i probably like i
it's stuff like that that i think is
really cool and that i wish could shine
in an episode like this like there's so
much i want to love about this and
there's so much it no i felt like it was
it rang really flat and i always come
back to just how does how do i feel when
it's done yeah um
and so
yeah that's unfortunate but i'm sure a
lot of people love it and you guys will
[ __ ] at us in the comments go for a go
for it yell at us tell us how we're
wrong
um
but to the next one i want to see what
happens next week oh yeah i feel like
it'll land with jonathan getting power
somehow i'm still super invested it just
feels like this episode was supposed to
be very important because ali's plan
comes to fruition it's not exactly like
a failed backdoor pilot
you know it feels like you're playing
some strange
it's yeah or like any show that does a
backdoor pilot it's not it's not a does
it's definitely not a backdoor pilot
like 100
but it's
the feeling i'm left with is akin to
that yeah that's a good way to put that
um
where you're like i don't really
i don't really like this this isn't as
good as what i've been watching because
it's like a different show and it's
doing things in a show i don't like
did you did you replace everybody just
for this episode is this the crew who's
gonna be making the spin off yeah and uh
i i think stylistically they didn't stop
stylistically do much different to it
and that other than like tinting it up
and really putting that red filter on
yeah all right guys we'll leave your
thoughts down below thanks for being
here
[Music]